so so today we're starting Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics in this class we're
just going to spend a weekend and we're
only going to look at two the two books
of it if this was the ethics class it
will take two years from now on it was
my ethics class three weeks or so on
Aristotle's Nicomachean ethics and we
look at it a bit more carefully and if
any of you are actually really
interested in that you can you can see
the videos from that class that are on
YouTube as well because I have given
lectures in that ethics class about but
one and I'm going to give you a somewhat
different lecture and discussion that I
did with the ethics class because we
have somewhat different interests so
when we think about ethics this is often
what we're thinking of right what is
good or bad for right or wrong and we're
typically thinking about people's
actions you know what is a good action
what's a bad action a lot of times are
our codes for ethics are encapsulated
and sort of list of statements right you
should do this you shouldn't do this
what would be a code like that that you
could think of
sometimes they we get in controversies
over whether this should be in
courtrooms or bring about with anybody
forgiving you can't there's tenant time
Commandments right the Ten Commandments
is an ethical code and it says what you
know it's on the really the basis big
basic things there's some things in
there that are purely religious like you
know you'll keep the Sabbath holy but
there's a lot of things in there like
you shouldn't kill people you shouldn't
steal you shouldn't lie you know so
false witness means it goes on actually
to talk a little bit about not just what
you want to do but also how you want to
be your feel right you shouldn't covet
your neighbor's wife or possessions or
this or that why should you know cover
neighbors husbands as well so it
prescribes behavior
desires that's an example of an ethical
color some of you are going into
professions that are going to have an
ethical codes to where you work in a
company that has a code of ethics right
and that will say well you can do this
or you can't do this you guys actually
are all under a code of ethics the
Student Conduct code right did you have
some discussion of that and orientation
when you first came in here with
students what do they tell you about it
I don't know because you know just
follow this here you read it now we're
done so what they did really what's in
it yeah sort of like staining drugs yeah
you're supposed to follow certain
certain rules
what about hitting a button for that
okay what if they really provoked you
what's difficult stuff does they have a
little provision in there that says
normally you shouldn't hit people but if
somebody's really got it coming to them
then maybe it's okay
probably categorical right probably says
no you shouldn't do that at all probably
got some things in there about internet
news so I'm guessing you know has a lot
of stuff in there about things specific
to students though doesn't it there's an
honor code actually if I want to when I
when I give you assignments I can click
a little box that requires you to affirm
that you know you're following the honor
code when you complete the assignment I
hadn't use that because you know better
than I do but I'm you know I'm guessing
it includes things like you're not going
to plagiarize you're not
somebody else's assignment is your own
you're not gonna buy assignments all
that sort of stuff
that ring a bell now that those those
have to do with you know good and bad
actions it's good for you to write your
own papers you don't like your own
papers then you're bad your van student
but you know that just gives us some
ideas about how we classify things does
it tell us why things are good or bad I
mean you could probably figure out why
it's a bad idea for you to go to the
paper mill and buy a paper but they
actually tell you that not really yeah
it leaves it up to you to figure that
out there are certain approaches to
ethics that just say here's what you
should do here's what you shouldn't do
okay we're done Aristotle doesn't do
that Aristotle had some of the other
people are gonna look at this semester
or like Plato when we look at they're
concerned with the effects that our
actions have on us not just on other
people but on us and the kind of life
that they they make for us so let's
think for example let's use this example
of you have to write a paper I'm going
to just go on through all this stuff you
know about final Colossus and all that
okay the final clause is something that
we call an end to purpose what's the
purpose in writing a paper why do you
write papers just because you love it
does that NAB sit in your dorm room and
just like wait and I'm just in case the
instructor might be ask you for a paper
on uncon somewhere down the line and
research it and write it there might be
a student somewhere who doesn't and I
doubt that that student right I wasn't
that student why do you write papers
yeah okay so you write the paper - why
didn't care about that why is it
important it sounds kind of you know
silly they ask because of course it's an
assignment you have to do it again you
know a lot of the places that I've
taught me Maris students are pretty good
with like doing what you asked I've been
at places where you assign things and
less than half of the class actually
does them good there's this kind of a
disconnect there they don't they don't
grasp when you students sort of
intuitively grasp because you've been
more or less brought up well you've been
initiated into thinking about things the
right way
why do you complete assignments because
the assignment is a component to do
great for the semester and zero really
affects your grade right that's another
lesson that so many of my students in
other places they would not do half of
the assignments and then be like so I've
got an F I really need to bring my grade
up to a see what can I do and I'd be
like well I mean there's not much you
can do at this point you know all those
zeros even if you you know ace the the
final exam you're you're gonna have a
half so you know consistently doing good
good work it's a good grade in the class
why do you want a good grade there might
be a lot of reasons right let's think
about the reason so what why do you want
why do you individual
I want a good grade say in this class
why do you care I know you do
because every one of you is here day
after day after day ready for class so
we can a so we do okay so it's it's
progress towards graduation is that the
only reason I don't think so for most of
you it might be for some of you and if
that's the case that's just people
because of that especially with required
classes you know spent my last several
years just teaching required classes
just as exited some behind philosophy
majors we didn't want to be in the
classes so I understand the motivation
of just wanting to get things done but
I'm willing to bet that's not the only
motivation why else do you care about
your grade in this class I can think of
two reasons about that
now your kids actually can't see your
grades you know because of her father
I forget exactly what it stands for it's
some sort of law and has to do with you
know what what of your information can
be there and I'm willing to bet though
most of your parents still want to see
their grades right and if you have all
DS for the semester how's that gonna pan
on at Christmastime yeah that's that's
understating it I a suspect right
especially since you know this is a
private school so this you know this
isn't just going to Community College
you know or to a state school where
things are still fairly cheap this is
you know somebody's paying for this and
they want to see a return on investment
all right what else though so you want
to go satisfy somebody else
okay so beyond graduation you want to
let's pull that career and that's a good
point because you know you can graduate
with a 2.0 but that's probably not going
to be what you need to get to do in grad
school right whales yeah so that you can
learn yes that's what I'll do when I
know that if any of it is let's call it
self respect you know you can you can
get by you can slough off and just get
by for a long time this isn't but you
notice that has effects on the way that
you feel about yourself when you live up
to your potential you feel when you and
so are you writing a paper let's go back
all the way to here when you write a
good paper you notice that you don't
just get a grade you actually feel
better about yourself
in the process and you probably do learn
something I mean if it's a good paper
you're demonstrating that you learn
something walk'n types these two are
connected the self respectable learning
when you realize this sort of progress
that you may need you know and you're
surprised by how much you actually know
that feels pretty good doesn't it sort
of like you know finding a skill that
you didn't
it's better than actually reaching into
your pocket and finding the $20 bill
that you left in there which you haven't
speaking sometimes sometimes it's just a
dollar bill because I'll go to a
conference and shove some money into a
coat that's that feels good but that's a
different kind of good feeling than
actually accomplishing something isn't
by a paper you could get by right you
can graduate there are people who do
this I don't know if it happens at
Marist but it happens at some schools
where they buy papers their entire
career you won't be ready for grad
school that's that's right I mean you
can you can buy big great papers the
entire time let's say you don't get
caught what happens when you say go to
them you know let's think of
professionals well you go to law school
and now you're actually required to
perform at a much higher level what's
going to happen here are you not going
to be able to do it your parents will be
ok because they won't know all right
what happens here's some perspective
here is they're buying papers how many
of you been to if let's say you would
you were really forced to do it you're
really under the gun this is a critical
class for you it's let's say it's your
last semester if you don't pass this
class you've really been struggling with
you're not going to graduate and a lot
of things have been happening in your
life that you didn't have any control
over like let's say you know sibling was
really sick and you were taking care of
them and now it's the last minute and
you need a paper you don't have it if
you don't buy a paper one of your
friends comes to you I know a site where
you buy a paper for 50 bucks if you
don't buy that paper you're not going to
graduate on time I won't actually ask
how many of you it's kind of a
hypothetical situation but you can
understand the temptation how many of
you would be tempted to do it yeah
that's understandable right and if you
would feel tempted you can probably
sympathize with somebody else who would
feel tempted you
stand there they're positional catcher
how would that affect your self-respect
later on it would have an effect on it
wouldn't it and you wouldn't learn
anything in the process other than maybe
what's in that paper as you read through
your life oh it's pretty good this is
this is the sort of thing means ends
reasoning I'm going from means to goals
or ends and I'm thinking about the goals
or ends or purposes of those and then
going out like that that we have to do
is we want to understand ethics well so
I mean this was a and this is good or
bad right writing your own papers is
good it's not writing your own papers as
bad but why well that all has to do with
this stuff over here it's not just
because not writing your own papers is
in the honor code as a bad thing it's in
the honor code as a bad thing because
all of this stuff over here it matters
and matters more in some respects than
the actual action of writing your own
paper so we not only need to know what
is good or what is right or wrong we
need
which is why and you remember this goes
back to what we've been talking about
for a week
why is asking for a cause
right could the answer to why is because
because what so now let's think about
Capulets so what makes what actually
makes me yeah we're gonna look at the
whole spectrum what makes you so we're
pretty much the whole board I think
family friends are quite the same thing
right let me they can overlap they'd
like to see you make your friends you
can't pick your family right you can't
do a certain extent you know when you
know you can't pick your family just
certain extent who you're gonna marry
because when you marry somebody as the
expression goes you don't just marry
that you marry their family and you
might say lats PS you know we're all
independent people but there's actually
some truth to that you know if you can't
stand that person's family
imagine that you're gonna be seeing that
I read Christmas and Easter and
Thanksgiving and stuff like that and
dealing so family and friends who who
else had family trends this is this pans
out pretty much with the other class of
a on the ethics class when I ask the
same question
almost everybody could pass entrance
what other things to people have yes
yeah that's important to health is are
good okay
success and that will be one that will
have to specify a little bit more as
well who else has something different
yeah well I was gonna say the same thing
like achieving goals but also God yeah
this is one that Aristotle doesn't talk
about but since you know judeo-christian
values got into our culture some people
think that that God might be the highest
end of life when we look at Thomas
Aquinas later in the semester he thinks
that happiness ultimately consists in
and then what else would I know they
were people at some other things as well
what else makes me happy
yeah I miss it sports I'm very very
myself because my team not only won the
Super Bowl last year that are there for
and oh you know the Green Bay Packers so
I can I can quite relate to that and the
only other team that's we call leisure
remember Aristotle says philosophy
metaphysics can only happen when
humanity actually has enough leisure to
be able to do it and it's not the
carpenters or the trades people who are
doing it it's the people who
actually have some time on their hands
how's the holidays holidays okay that's
interesting I've never heard that isn't
the answer to this what is it about
holidays it's actually because that's an
interesting answer oh I can understand
that holidays can also be the most
stressful time of the year too if
they're managed very badly yeah that's
another one that I have but you know
again that makes good sense I had when I
went to undergrad it was in Wisconsin
and Wisconsin's about on the same
latitude as here so you all know you
know days get shorter and the night's
get longer we're already moving towards
that I have friends who at work second
and third shift jobs and so they would
they would actually be asleep during the
day and there's something called
seasonal affective disorder right sad
you guys have heard of that we so call
it being stir-crazy people actually get
depressed because they're not seeing the
Sun for days and days I have that does
in fact affect us that hasn't
yeah sort of general law of a romantic
lover
yeah well that's romantic love right
yeah it's not just because you don't
want a boyfriend or girlfriend we just
were there nice to be around but you
don't not attracted to that right that
romantic love is is something important
some people can actually become addicted
to that it's that good of a fuel this is
a pretty good list you guys have any
others here so this is the totality
let's swimming with the line here is
there anything for this second question
what are you thinking happy life for you
is going to include what does the kind
of life that you're shooting for is
there anything in this list that but is
there anything any questions any answers
to this question that aren't on this
list already yeah okay so let me ask
this for the whole class all of you of
course need some money right because you
can't can't do anything without some
money you want to go to Starbucks
you need some about five bucks just
about to get a decent latte so you all
need some money money is not that bigger
than value for you right now
all right compared to other things but
you anticipate in the future it will be
how many do you think it's going to be a
really important value for you how many
of you are thinking about going into
careers and one of the reasons why you
want to go into that
a lot of money just a few me that's
that's a motivator money is important
and any other things that were in your
list of where you're trying to go that
aren't over here besides money yeah
traveling okay enjoy going to different
places yeah okay yeah oh you know you
just play okay let's work with what
we've got here this is a great list so
Aristotle talks about some of these and
actually if we think about certain of
the ages we could kind of roll them into
each other or we could say that we like
that because of other things having a
home it's interesting you said a home
not a house right there is a difference
between a house and a home
these are fit under the generic category
of what we call well they're your
possessions your wealth is not just the
money that you have in your wallet it
also includes the goals that you have
possessions the toys the tools all those
sorts of things that are harder well for
some of you your wealth might also
consist in intellectual capital you know
you guys are acquiring important skills
that could be part of your your wealth
your abilities but for the most part
time we think of well if you think of it
in terms of money things you can buy
with money things that you can you can
have with money or money itself yeah
wealth is important Aristotle does
think that that wealth is useless
there's a lot of things in here that
could fit in with another motive that he
talks about which is butter right why do
people like to watch sports are they
improving their minds they're buying I
mean maybe you learning stats about you
know this is this person's career is
that really important knowledge about a
sportscaster
or something like that what's important
knowledge they have yeah knowledge they
can get you places that's a good good
broad generic answer they can cover a
lot of ground yeah we're gonna say
common sense yeah that actually it's
interesting common sense has to be
developed right it's not something I
remember when I was a kid I didn't have
a lot of common sense and I remember my
dad couldn't relate to this seeing me do
some things and say oh you just don't
have any common sense okay so what
should I have done common sense would
have told you to do this right but now
that you probably have back to pleasure
so you watch sports events there could
be some other modes you watch your kid
playing because you feel the kind of
sense of pride in doing so where you
want you're going to watch to support
the team right you're doing it for the
other person for the most probably watch
sports because we've got the horse we're
gonna say we like to see people like
succeed their levels that we might not
be able to that's interesting like when
people watch sports they see people with
all these extraordinary things that they
realize that a lot of them couldn't do
yeah the same thing goes for movies too
doesn't it yeah a lot of extraordinary
things happen yeah we can't all be
mutants who save the world or
there's some other popular things can't
acquit Paltrow you like Brad Pitt I
guess all these probably dated for you
guys right probably to a whole no okay
what else can't you do that that does
happen in the race well travel and I
mean you can't travel a lot of the
places that are depicted as movies
because there are actually sets and they
don't exist anymore
you can't fight medieval battles or
dragons or find aliens or maybe you
can't fight anyways if they show up
maybe some yeah so getting to put
yourself into kind of a story or see see
amazing things again that's that's a
kind of pleasure food is also a good
example I mean you food is are good if
you don't eat any food what happens yeah
yeah either you die or they take you to
the hospital yeah they they start you
know giving you the food down tube down
your throat or they they put it in
through your veins or stuff like that
because you have to have food to exist
that's not all that we do with food that
what is that who lives on food that's
just what they need and they're not
concerned about the taste of anything
oatmeal's my my sort of prime example of
boring food maybe you like oatmeal
I don't I
sort of doing penance and also because
now that I'm older you know if I want to
be healthy I'm supposed to eat from my
heart so I know I hate it but I eat it
like you know three or four times a week
I'd rather have cookies because cookies
taste good right
food can bring you a lot of different
kinds of pleasures think about the
Culinary Institute of America I've
talked about it a couple times because
it's right down the road from you any of
you haven't gone there you should go
there to see some of the amazing things
that these people do with food on a
routine basis day after day after day
take the paper to it especially though
go in and take the tour part where you
see the cake making and the chocolate
making and just amazing things that
makes people do those are to the white
not just the palate but also to the
light the eyes the gears all those other
the imagination that's about pleasure
right well you might be you might have
your friends just for pleasure safety I
hope that all of you have some friends
that you find pleasant to be with
because what's the alternative
you couldn't be friends with them just
because they're useful to you because
they pay your way for things all right
there are people who are friends on that
basis or have associations Aristotle
understands that hope your family is
pleasant to be with if holidays are
Pleasant for you
odds are it's because your family is
actually pleasant to be with if you
don't have such a family they know some
friends don't you're probably not going
to like to spend a lot of time with nice
weather I think is probably a matter of
pleasure as well as enough well today's
a beautiful day it's almost a shame to
be inside
it's not going to be so nice pretty soon
visit except for those who really like
cold and snow and slush and slipping and
your fingers and toes hurting from
what's that someone doesn't like my turn
your loved ones your what you will
derive a lot of pleasure you know I like
about winter being inside well they have
and I also like doing some of the
activities outside like shoveling the
snow believe it or not and I like I like
seeing all the ice on the trees that's
kind of pretty but as I got older I
don't do that too much but but if you
like it more power to you you get
pleasure on pleasures are good pleasure
is a good thing we pursue pleasure
because we actually enjoy it and
Aristotle doesn't think that you should
try to avoid pleasure you know for its
own sake and you should live a life
devoid of pleasure he understands with
this that's important what else do we
have in here success now that's when we
have to explore a little bit so what
does being successful consistently but I
bet that for most of you being
successful is not just a matter of being
wealthy is what else makes up success
for you this goes back to what do you
imagine a happy life for you is first of
all where are you where are you
successful usually pretty successful in
how a while you sleep we talk about
people being successful there we talk
about people being successful because
they eat really good food I suppose we
could think of something way in which
that could be success so what do we
think
success what do you get what would
success gonna be like for you I hope all
of you are gonna be successful like okay
so that that's sort of an intermediary
type of success and those are all
important things gaining knowledge all
of you should come out of college a lot
smarter within certain ways that you
came in all right otherwise wasting your
money we're wasting somebody else's
money and getting the the certificate
getting the bachelor's that's that's a
measure of success what else what's
gonna come after that four I'm guessing
all career yeah well some are planning
to go to grad school right what are some
of the other things you want to do other
than stay in school for a longer time
which I can understand I like being in
school what else getting a job right so
there's gonna be something that you're
going to do some of you are going to be
working as psychologists some of you are
going to be buying and selling things
some of you are going to be making
people happy clients happy in one way or
another you know trying to figure out
what it is that they actually want deep
in their heart and then make that happen
some of you are going to be doctors and
there are new lawyers some of you are
actually going to discover that you like
working with your hands and you'll get a
BA or a BS or VPS and then switch
careers and become a baker or a
carpenter or something like that but for
all of you you will be doing something
actually some of you have may end up
staying and staying at home and doing
things some of you may become writers
some of you may just run a household but
there are measures for what counts as
success
all right what is a successful career
look like yeah I think it's something
that makes you happy
ah that's that's a good point
what does actually make you happy with
respect to work being able to achieve
all those kinds of things so they should
be job that helps you achieve those
things and money's a part of it again
okay so that's so these are all sort of
ends then for the job the dessert are
there any job that you like doing by
themselves and you would do even if you
didn't get some of these other things
this is part of the difference between a
career in the streets and or a calling
and a job well right when I was a kid we
had to read this papal encyclical which
is on human labor and it made a
distinction between having a job which
was a good thing to have a job because
you can provide you know for family you
can contribute to the community and do
all these things and then having a
calling I'm guessing that many of you
have a calling to the kind of work that
you're eventually going to be doing it
may not actually be what you think it's
going to be right now I would have never
guessed when I was your age that I was
going to be a college professor that I'd
loved being a college professor
you have been doing and see myself doing
as the rest of my life
did you had told me that when I was your
age I would have said you're nuts
because actually at your age this is
gonna really strike you kind of fights
didn't guess what it would what I
thought I was gonna be they're coming
not because it's really crazy I was
gonna be a mercenary I went in the army
so I could gain experience I became a
combat engineer so I could learn how to
handle demolitions yeah do you know
infantry kind of stuff and I it was in a
bunch of you know the guys in Iran with
in high school one of them had an uncle
who's actually mercenary and had made
money with that so he'll stay yeah so we
all studied martial arts and we all went
in the army to gain experience we have
this big plans that we're all going to
get together after time we studied extra
languages and we're on a bivouac and
making providing munitions and things
when we were your age you know we're
pretty pretty motivated pretty crazy too
all of that just you know that was a
pine tree and then I think about what I
was going to do and again you know I
went to school like you guys did and I
can't say that actually at your age I
applied myself all that much as an
undergraduate I kind of screwed around a
bit and I got a degree in philosophy and
I got a degree in mathematics so then I
didn't go to graduate school right after
that I worked as I worked as what we now
call a barista you know in a coffee
house
and as a third shift security guard in a
big office building at the same time and
then you know studied languages on the
side and that's it and then I ended up
applying for a graduate school a year
later because I realized you know
there's working stuff with
the VA in philosophy of mathematics kind
of you know wasn't what I really wanted
to do he and I had to decide Chicago for
math or for philosophy
I love philosophy more than I love
mathematics but I didn't sort of think
ahead about what am I actually gonna do
with a philosophy PhD I just wanted to
study philosophy so I went to grad
school for that nothing turned out that
this is more or less what you do with it
there's a lot of other things you do too
but I really like doing this I enjoy
doing this and even if even if it didn't
bring me friends or it doesn't give me a
lot of sleep or necessarily a lot of
money or wealth or anything like that
doesn't do anything with sports I would
keep doing this but I still do keep
doing this because I really find
satisfaction so part of what I hope for
all of you guys is that you have
something like that and success for you
will be more than just getting a lot of
stuff for the work you do I hope that
you do get a lot of stuff for what you
do so if you put in a lot of hard work
there should be some compensations right
but I hope then all of you find
something in your life that you can do
eight hours a day that you love doing
that would be great
you know there's a lot of things that
that we can think of with success you
can think of somebody being a big shot
having a reputation right that's an
important part of success for some
people for other people it's that
satisfaction in what you do that's part
of what Aristotle calls virtuous
activity so when you were reading
through this new read virtuous activity
you know what is that think about a
career that you're gonna have you know
maybe maybe you're going to be a doctor
or a nurse or a social worker or
something like that where you're
actually helping people you're virtuous
activity will be doing that well and
improving people's lives if you are a
carpenter or a contractor or a plumber
or something like that it's going to be
improving people's lives through
building wealth through fitting pipes
well those of you who are doing a
fashion thing you'll be bringing
pleasure to people's lives and like we
said earlier you know a couple of days
ago I think making people actually feel
good about the way they look by giving
them clothes that make them look good
that will be part of success if that's
where you're headed
so work some other things are there any
other things that you can think of that
make other people happy here's where we
can get a type of crazy facts think
about some of the celebrities and the
things that you look at their lives you
know well I guess that must be what they
really like but I can't picture that
working for me or people who have lives
that are totally screwed up they want
something they desire something and
they're probably getting it what are
some some other things that people
desire or that you can
yeah like attention oh yeah that's a
good one it will often want attention
for doing something before they've
actually done it and then that's why
they do it and you can say they're not
doing it because they love that or
because I think it's a good thing they
just want attention from us right and
people do a lot of stupid things for
attention what else what other crazy
things
well that is fairly crazy just not
likely to be candidates for them good
life people want some people just want
to get high you know spending on the
dropping me off and call me habits you
know if you're if you're hooked that
hero or mouth or crack your life's over
practically speaking you might be able
to manage for a little while and keep
things together pretty soon you know
everything's gonna be gone you know but
people who have those sort of addictions
they're constantly on the make to try to
get that drug why do they want that's
right you know yes it is a pleasure
people people like drugs because drugs
are very pleasant they're also you know
pretty harmful that's why we tell you
not to take them
we also don't get a lot done with your
if you're doing drugs unless it's a
certain extent math you know cocaine
cocaine is like the drug that that high
performers would take back in the
eighties so they could you know stay
awake off like before but it really
destroys your body they have destroyed
your mind yeah but then it's something
that people think is gonna make them
happy isn't it
otherwise they wouldn't do the drums can
you think of anything else like that
things that we can look at and say
that's that's not a good idea but people
for eating food can be used and food can
be abused or how many of you see these
reality shows my quarters many you seen
that show that's pretty amazing some of
the stuff that those people live in and
it has to do with you know holding onto
possessions but it's not possessions
like you know we tend to think of it's
just a whole bunch of stuff you know
some of it gone bad
what else
mother the reality shows are probably a
great way to think of some of these
things attention a lot of attention
seeking people in reality shows are
there any of the things that people want
from those yet oh that's a good question
let's think of some examples to be
accepted for something that's yeah so
you be looking to be accepted by people
who have a screwed up idea of what's
good and bad so you want to get in good
with well I'll give you an example
the crowd that I hung out with if I was
in school was called burnouts and I
don't know if they kept up any
department in high schools now these are
the kids who you know work for leather
jackets or jean jackets and listen to
heavy metal and got in fights and you
know stole things and grow things and
fought with the jocks and and was there
a group like that known in sir
I guess what needs you act like that
though well that's that's a good
question because I've never understood
like why people someone that had to do
with acceptance I was looking for
acceptance from from some in a certain
group of people like you want to be
accepted by a group yeah I like the guys
that I hope yeah and I also you know I
wanted to be kind of a tough guy and you
know I had all sorts of crazy notions of
that gun movies and songs on when I tell
you guys about this stuff that say lost
lungs are not a good guide to how you
ought to run your life I know because
I've actually done that so I was looking
for except from the wrong crowd and so I
did a lot of stupid things like getting
in fights and stealing things along with
other guys who were stealing things
talking about it and then afterwards you
look at well a lot of drinking you think
about that you say why was that stupid
what did I get out of that nothing
yeah boys you've learned the right
things the new knowledge by doing by
doing it wrong yes you can tell us
that's bad yeah here you go you're right
there is some value in that but that's a
very that's a very conditioned to
limited value isn't Aristotle we're
going to put what Aristotle
one thing in terms of means and ends
well the pursuit of wealth the life of
wealth-getting cannot really be the
happy life why not well because why do
you pursue well what's it good for
other stuff right we've talked about
this before money is only good because
you can buy stuff with having a
beautiful house it was only good because
you live in it entertain friends in it
it's not good in and of itself isn't
those people who are on hoarders they're
a great example of people who have
gotten screwed up somehow in their their
priorities and they think just
accumulating all this stuff is going to
make them happy
what are the other candidates he talked
about pleasure
so wealth is something we pursue for the
sake of other things are the things that
we pursued for their own sake pleasure
yeah you do pursue pleasure for our own
for its own sake
right if you ask somebody why are you
doing that and they say because I like
doing it that's a reasonable answer
isn't because I enjoyed reputation or
what he calls honor that's that's
something that motivates because
question that may tighten with what ms
doxa was calling acceptance or you know
who brought up attention as possibly a
bad thing so attention could be
reputational success can often be we're
pursuing reputation and it might be
reputation in other people's eyes it
might be reputation in the eyes of
somebody's long debt there are people
who are trying to please dead parents
and show that they've actually made it
and that's not a very happy life
actually but they think that it's going
to make consensus what we often value
before what you know Aristotle says why
do people get a good reputation it's for
what he calls virtue for another thing
anything about virtue moral goodness
somebody isn't just personal somebody is
an honorable person that's why people
like them you know you guys have
probably already at this point fluffed
off a few of your high school friends
and when it comes to Thanksgiving this
little big messes you're gonna go home
and you're gonna hang out with some of
your high school friends you're not
gonna hang out with other of your high
school friends and hopefully the choices
not just based on who's in town it's
based on things like who do you actually
want to be with who can you relate to
who is worth being around who's loyal
who's gonna stand up for you wonder
stand up for that's called courage who
can you rely on to make good decisions
those are all virtues that's one thing
that some people think is worth pursuing
I suspect most of you too then of course
there's there's knowledge and you can
pursue knowledge just because you know
you need it so that you can go to the
next step in your career or you can
pursue knowledge for its own sake again
one of my hopes for all of you is that
you find something that you like to
learn about just for its own sake not
just a passive class not just to make it
to the next step in your career
fix-a-flat yes like that but then you
find something you really enjoy knowing
about and you would get to spend time
doing that maybe you can do that as your
career so Aristotle says okay these are
all prisoners for their own sake they're
also all pursued because people think
they're going to bring them happiness so
let's think about these experiments he
says could pleasure be the life of
pleasure could that really be the life
with a happy life and he says well a lot
of people think so
but there's something there's something
missing there you can actually have a
life full of all sorts of pleasures and
still feel empty still feel that there's
something lacking and a lot of people do
go through this they do work their butts
off and then they make a lot of money
and then they buy a lot of nice things
and then they feel very empty inside a
lot of pleasures if you can just pursue
them they end up you know not not
turning out to be so great when you're
in the courtship stage yeah you know I
can't stand and not be with the person
everything they say is so funny or
profound or you know so great and it
hurts all the water and all that I mean
you go out with them and it's you're
having a great time and then
turns out that three months later you
realize you can't stay on the way they
laugh or the stuff that they laugh at or
what else do people complain about they
have other habits that annoy you we're
doing nothing with their life they show
no ambition that's why they have so much
time to spend with because they don't do
anything you know all other references
are from pop culture and are really
starting to bore you movie quotes that
they were they were you know using his
catchphrases three months ago again
stale well that's an example of pleasure
not turning out to remain Pleasant so
the life of pleasure is kind of a
slavish are I mean you could you could
say he's already married that can
satisfy you if that does truly satisfy
you Aristotle says you're missing out on
something distinctively human these
other things like knowledge or moral
virtue or even reputation or honor those
are more distinctively human the life of
sheer pleasure a dog can with like that
big can live like that well reputation
they're hotter that's not really the
be-all and end-all because why do people
seek to be you know respected or honored
or admired it's pretty having some good
quality right I mean I think there are
some celebrities who just want people to
look at them and they don't care whether
they look at them in a good way jive
with your your take on some celebrities
so maybe that could be this but most
people actually want to be respected for
something you know what about this
Aristotle says welcome even virtue by
itself is not complete it's getting
closer to
but you can be virtuous and be asleep
all the time you know you could have the
right happiness but not actually
exercising so what does happiness going
to be for your soul it's going to be a
lie virtuous activity that's the keep in
their activity it's going to have
sufficient well because you've said well
you're Aristotle says if you're
dirt-poor you can be a really good
person but you're gonna have a miserable
life you know if you can't afford
medicine you can't afford food you can't
be you can't feed clothe house your
family you can be a great person but
you're not going to be very happy
according to Aristotle you might
different right some of you may think
that the life of a poor you know worker
taking care of other people might
actually be a happy life various levels
doesn't think so I'm not saying that you
have to think that way I'm just telling
you what does view is it's also going to
be a life friends and family Aristotle
thinks that you guys are right friends
and family are a constituent part of
being happy but he thinks that if you
have friends and family and you have
wealth but you don't have a virtuous
activity you're still not going to be
completely happy some people put all
their priority and friends and family
and they don't look at their own their
own life their own character and they
don't have nothing actually being happy
if you actually do have a life a
virtuous activity Aristotle says it's
going to be because you know if what
what you know does it for you is taking
care of people and you get to take care
of people you're gonna be you're gonna
enjoy that right if what really does it
for you is
getting to meet people or traveling or
things like that then you actually get
to do that in the course of your
virtuous activity you're going to have a
a pleasant life now notice that you're
not aiming at pleasure directly
pleasures sort of a byproduct choosing
something other than pleasure if you try
to shoot for pleasures straight off very
often you don't get it let's use the
example of romantic love again right
because I think that's one you can all
relate to it's a great example you could
try to find somebody who right off the
bat has all the qualities that please
you you know you could go on match.com
and you have never actually been on one
of those sites but I assumed there's
something like a checklist I'm looking
for somebody who's you know tall rather
than shorts who is you know was a
nonsmoker who likes cats and dogs who
you know all these things is that is
anybody have any of you ever been have
one of those sites there was no one
anybody who could use one of those sites
let's assume it right would then
actually make you yeah you know you're
gonna date with them you having a good
time you may not actually be happy in
the long run what about building a life
with somebody what is it what does that
take how many of you that have been in a
long-term relationship like something
maybe six months or longer so eventually
you got a tired person you're with right
you got on your nerves never how did you
get through
it's all the house they're thinking that
others feel some things that that's
quite bad you work on if you want to
stay together you actually have to like
working on things else anything else
workers yeah you're right because then
you're suffering in silence and then you
have to like put on a face so
everything's okay they might see through
that or they might not a life that you
live together is not going to be a life
of you know as they say a wine and roses
all the time but the pleasures that can
come from a long-term relationship where
you actually develop with that person
the pleasures that can come from that
ultimately are much greater much deeper
this is where we talk about intimacy I
mean a lot of people talk about intimacy
they mean having sex with somebody and
there is a certain you know sense of
that because you know people are
together they're they're enjoying
themselves hopefully and all sorts of
things are taking place and they feel
this way in that way but real intimacy
is something that develops over a long
time and it actually takes some trials
and requires you to make some choices
but the pleasures that can come with
that as a result not as what you
actually aim for are much greater than
the pleasures that you would get just by
going out and sleeping with whoever you
know change the best at the time
Aristotle's you know this was true in
Aristotle's time it's a pretty hard time
and will be true for for your children
as well so Aristotle has given us one
vision of human happiness let's end with
with this where else in our culture are
people giving us visions of human
happiness
on TV yeah okay so what are some
examples of that you have a happy these
spending time with their family
everything's perfect big house where do
you agree to see that the sitcoms yeah
some of them all those who comes they
don't stay interesting long unless
people have conflicts right can't all be
perfect all the time yeah what else it
wasn't and they may be trying to go do
virtuous activity here's what else what
other shows or things on TV we're
presenting you with visions even very
short visions so it comes when you watch
reality shows you get to see what other
people think the handy life is sometimes
but that's not telling you hey you
should live with this let anybody tell
you that you should live a certain way
or see certain things is necessary for
your happiness in 30 seconds or less
Marshalls right I mean there's a whole
industry out there that is trying to
tell you this is going to make you happy
usually by appealing to pleasure or
reputation or or wealth think about
those acts commercials right I used to
and in one of my classes they should
show there would be like two days around
show commercials than we do in the
Alice's of them and they use those acts
of bullying chicken wah-wah commercials
you know those are male fantasies that
are being played out and the reason why
act sells so much is because there's a
lot of guys out there who on a
subconscious level are saying what are
they happy if I buy